what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation my God I have had this
movie muted on all my social medias for
far too long now so we could react to it
right here and that is of course Scream
Six join of course with John who is
rocking a shirt to my favorite horror
movie franchise but now he's the winner
thank you John for being here and Andrew
ready to ruin this movie by constantly
pointing out Easter eggs the whole time
and predicting the killer way too early
on how are you Andrew of course now I'm
gonna predict the wrong killer thanks
for putting that kind of pressure on me
I'm good uh ready to watch stab sick or
Scream Six rather and uh already with
the references I know you prep that joke
two weeks ago and he's delivering it
today people hey
leave a like
stab that like button also massive thank
you to all who have followed us on our
patreon page we've been covering Sony
movie reactions around the channel we've
got an influx of patrons so thank you
super sexy rejects for joining us so as
always full length Reaction watch alongs
where you sync up with your own copy of
scream sticks available for super sex
Rejects at our patreon page but we also
cover several things exclusively over
there for the reaction highlights and
watch along is included gentlemen are
you ready to do this let's do it I'm
ready
are you doing an impression of my uncle
Greg
[Music]
hey
oh that's Samara Samara weaving share
first victim or our first fake out
uh-oh Reggie so nice to phone meet you
in this incredibly embarrassing way it's
very cool restaurant is it on Hudson yes
uh I'm now walking towards Hudson voice
sounds familiar this is not the first
impression I wanted to make on a college
professor it's just film studies so oh
what do you know cinema cinema try
teaching at class on 20th century
slashes to a heap of hun over 19 year
olds I love this class sign me up what's
your favorite scary movie not that one
out of those cliches comes an
opportunity for Outsider Art a voice for
the voiceless you might say that's this
movie what color is the outside of the
restaurant I I think it's red I don't
see anything red yep it's definitely red
yeah I'm not seeing anything red here oh
you will it'll be on your dress
oh it looks like there's an alley I can
cut through is the restaurant near an
alley
what a way to lure ooh scarecrow
he's staring at me what oh [__] he's
following me I don't I don't see anybody
oh he's clever yeah where are you are
you oh he's got a knife
it's like a video game voiceover sounds
familiar Clash about slashers and you
still walked into a dark alley yeah
that's not funny no
it's not
oh whoa
holy [__]
[Music]
wow now I see something red
as an angry ghost face clever opening
oh what the hell damn it I uh I can
totally hear it now oh this is a flip
yeah
foreign
does anyone have eyes on Parker
he's logged in
Ned too
oh hey Tara Jason uh do you think we're
gonna come to the okb party we will is
your sister coming
oh my God I think Tony River Laurie's
the killer I was gonna say can you guys
any ideas who the Killer is I know I
think Tony River Lori is about to get
the boot right now too
The Cult of ghost face
out damn spot why would Luke just throw
the lightsaber over his shoulder
[Laughter]
not my Star War I just got massive blue
balls and I had to practice please don't
be mad I'm not
dude we said we wouldn't use the voice
on each other
turn off the voice modulator I'm just
trying to get the voice right you got to
have your practice I get mine
uh tell me what it felt like all right
fine
it was even better yeah Friday the 13th
Takes Manhattan where are we just
talking about
she wasn't human
anymore I get what you mean just an
animal
yeah just meat she was
just meat but she wasn't just meat Jason
she was a person our film Professor ah
I just want you to tell me why you think
you're doing this we're finishing
Richie's film that's right oh
cool are you using the cameras yeah the
cameras all right douchebag let's play
so strange
he's in the washing machine
I'm gonna hang up now but you're getting
warmer
he's behind you taped to your back
oh oh he's dead
armor
you're on fire
awesome tank did you feel like an animal
Jason
whoa
wow
oh
my goodness we have to finish the movie
who gives up about movies yeah we do
we give a flip about movies that is an
intriguing hook it's like multi-level
marketing of Ghostface if you invite
five horror fans and they find five
horror fans
so how are the new meds treating you
Billy's right next to her this group
therapy but I'm really worried about is
you it's how your sister isn't dealing
with whatever happened to both of you a
year ago yeah whatever happens
checks notes murder
last year I found out that my boyfriend
was also a serial killer him and his
psycho girlfriend killed a bunch of
people this crazy rumor started online
that I orchestrated the whole thing and
framed them this dude's going to need
therapy yeah
Richie was my boyfriend wow
but you didn't
could you say that a little louder
please and how how did you stop him
I stabbed him 22 times and slit his
throat
but that's not why I'm here
why are you here Prozac because
it felt right fascinating by law I'm
required to report this to the authority
I didn't say I was going to do anything
not explicitly no you know
she even implies she's gonna do it yeah
and all this stuff in the past would
have been like it's already reported
yeah yeah there was copster and
everything she should think about Zoom
therapy that's what happens when you go
to betterhelp.com
Elm Court clever
[Music]
way being too loud
where's Tara she went to the Omega Kappa
beta party
um
I've been checking each other out for
months why don't you just talk to him
I'm gonna go find Tara is that that
wasn't Frenchy was it no man it's Adrian
uh from Arrow and then the guy in
She-Hulk
Mindy
Meeks Martin being at a house party
after you were almost brutally murdered
at a house party no I think of it like
being struck by lightning the odds of it
happening twice to the same person are
extremely low haha especially when
you're the killer I got a bottle of
Fireball up in my room
wow subtle you want to call it a night I
think that I'm actually still gonna hang
but you guys don't have to wait for me
don't worry I'll take care of it sure
you will Tara's good down here
sorry bro I didn't catch up you heard
exactly what he said
it's fine I want to yeah see chat
it's okay she wants to come on don't
behave like that though it's gonna tase
you in the balls real quick
you're stalking me now
oh yeah it's that psycho girl psycho
also a movie reference
have you the rest of my life so you're
just gonna pretend it never happened
you have post-traumatic stress disorder
I was trying to look out for you I
know you are
you can't do it for the
rest
Jesus that is so messed up I have
tissues if you want tissues
I have like three tissues I'll die on
the Mojo I'm going with Ethan as the one
of the killers go back to your dorm I'm
pretty sure the fighting is done for the
day
um
oh
thank you for
uh
I think you're really special oh
don't do it guys conflicted don't do it
guys
post-traumatic stress disorder hookup is
the best dude
whoa he's secretly Richie's brother not
ready for your sister and your friends
to know that you enjoy physical contact
with another
get up here right now the mutilated
bodies
uh Secrets out Jason Carvey and
holy [__] that's that from
from getting out of the city what thank
you very much suspicious new game and I
think we got it from here
[Laughter]
that was great Quinn
before you make the unilateral decision
to abandon my college education and flee
the state
I'm calling him now thank you
Gail what
I said afraid I need you to come down to
the station
I would love it if she is the killer I
would love it I think it's smart keeping
their attention the also the Harding and
conflict of the story yes it's really a
smart call
what
show the world who you really are a liar
and a killer you shouldn't believe
everything you read on the internet yeah
Riddler you and Tara better watch
you better watch yours
whoa you better watch
dang
I'm lying here girls
holy [__] you got a problem here guys
kill him
oh jeez [__] lovely yes I like this
ghost face
doesn't care about public places
or anyone who gets in the way
oh
damn
oh he's like The Punisher oh this is
awesome
I'm here for shotgun ghost face boy
I love how worn down that mask is too
it's got to be from before
that'll work
yeah stealthy they've been making so
much there's enough noise
yeah
and grab some groceries on the way out
oh
arrest Sam she did it clearly do either
of you have any
besides everyone
not anyone who's still alive thanks
FBI's here claiming jurisdiction Sydney
works for the F yes oh hey
yes
[Music]
she is part of the FBI okay cool Ghost
Face killers of 2011. we're just leaving
them on purpose which means whoever's
doing this is a student of the killers
who came before maybe he believes Sam's
the latest in a long line yeah
[Laughter]
my bad I did I didn't realize
but I've done this dance before Oh
I talked to Sydney
oh she wants more money she sends her
love but she's taking Mark and the kids
someplace safe Patrick Dempsey she
deserves to have her happy ending so
that means she'll be in the next one
right
[Music]
oh so the victims are not personal
they're targeted specifically to frame
you're a day
reading you know
you know wow
[Laughter]
in the face what a pointless glass
yes watch through it decorative
oh there gotta be a bunch of Easter eggs
in those names I love him he's like a
yes I was waiting for this song
can't do a screen movie without it I
don't care what location you change your
damn stream movie too someone is out to
make a sequel stab one took place
tomorrow
College suspicious new characters
brought in to round out the suspect list
and or body count check check we're not
in a sequel because nobody just makes
sequels anymore we're in a franchise you
can't just stay at the hospital
everything is bigger than last time
bigger budget bigger cast bigger body
count no Sydney whatever happened last
time expect the opposite franchises only
Survive by subverting expectations did
Ryan Johnson write this Legacy
characters cannon fodder at this point
usually brought back only to be killed
off in some cheap bid for Nostalgia bye
Gail wow main characters are
oh boy am I in the friend group yeah am
I like one of the targets and yes not
Evan Peters you are the shy dorky guy
who no one suspects because he's so shy
and okay wait why am I on the suspect
list I suspect them Quinn
the [__] roommate
we better
that makes it more likely that she's the
Killer because having a [__] dad is a
great cover do you not remember how
these movies work
tell it I think it's pretty safe to rule
out the four of us who went through this
last year no no different expectations
what if the trauma you all went through
caused one or four more of you to snap
what a smart [__] person
I mean face facts if we're all suspects
you're all suspects
everybody's a suspect including Kirby so
the prime suspect is
this poor woman yeah
on the street last night
life of a Survivor there's also
mountains of evidence
Sam if you did it it's okay none of us
can relate to what you are experiencing
and I'm really really sorry that you
have to do that alone oh
there is so much more I like about this
movie than the last one there's so much
more I've all been through some [__]
up stuff and we are coping with it
differently I mean we moved here
together for one very specific reason to
wreak havoc on New York
[Laughter]
we are
the core
[Laughter]
there we go I've been sleeping with cute
boy from across
so he's the new Jerry O'Connell holy
[__] hey yeah what's up [__]
oh [__] damn Samantha throw something in
the window frustrating
hey not right now
I wish I could enjoy this no no
back at it again
oh smart to do that that fake out
earlier uh send her a text
send her a text
oh oh no
run woof
foreign
yes the Butcher Block smash his face in
oh
evil dies tonight right here right here
get your hands away from the door
dude this ghost face is actually scary
[__] go hard
you have to come one at a time somebody
let's go
Mindy's the killer I feel like it could
be yeah or Chad I mean nope Mindy I go
Mindy I'm still keeping my Ethan pick
ing more positive I don't miss it come
on damn there's so much tension Mindy
offering to stay could be sus though and
she wasn't killed she was just hitting
the arm
ah I would work on like sliding the door
oh this is so sad but I'd rather her die
than Mindy
[Music]
oh I think America's gonna fall this is
giving me home alone vibes
oh no we go she gonna fall oh God
goodbye
[Music]
oh this is so scary
oh what a day sure
dick face
oh man that is so cruel
oh
man
I love this ghost face yeah he is
actually scary this is hard man's
actually scary I breather I feel like
Ghostface hasn't been legitimate he's
scary at all as much as I love this
whole franchise I'm like this guy's
actually kind of terrified
[Music]
anyone
anyone friends not me
not anymore
but especially the police
don't trust the FBI but you know live in
the moment
where were you when when last night dude
I was in a study hall with a hundred
other people you can ask any of them
bring me on 100 nope
I'm so sorry step back
you're at the top of my list damn it
I was wrong it's not him no no it could
be still could be I know but it seems
too obvious now and that's what they do
in this franchise sometimes it's the
most obvious sometimes it's the least
obvious
ly oh this poor guy
it's giving me shades of Halloween where
Sheriff Becker lost his daughter they
took me out of the case
I'm not gonna stop until I find him my
family
you die oh quarter mile at a time boy
you okay I came as soon as I heard Dale
I swear to God no
truth okay they work together on Friends
reunion we didn't know we needed it's
really meta right now I know where the
masks are coming from
Kirby
Carol
interesting Jason and Greg were little
Atlanta Rich boys doesn't make sense
don't worry I'm just really good at my
job you'll get there why is she so
competitive with a Kirby
Kirby too half your age too what is
it's giving me shades of scream three
it's a shrine Gail here is giving me
shades of all the Scream movies that
came before this one
's faces are giving me all the shades of
every screen
Drew Barrymore Casey Becker hey hey
she's in the movie there you go they
could afford the pictures oh [__] about
the whole God franchise
stab three scripts how much do you think
this could cost these guys the first one
right there yeah Steve
Henry Winkler principal
oh Dewey R.I.P cops like money and
evidence can get lost pretty easily
present company excluded of course
suspects my alibi checks out so I can
keep an eye on you Roomie
this poor guy I hope he's the hero yeah
I told you I was just a guy the question
is do you guys think it's one or two
though two
damn how [__] cool is this place Papa
can you hear me he's back I hear your
horror fan
it's been set
best Nightmare on Elm Street the
original and three psycho two is
underrated yes did we just become best
friends yup I think I might have an idea
about how to turn the tables on this
creep yeah we're in
sorry Gail no press allowed Police
business
my job too but all you suspects in
Victor come with me I got all you
covered
so we're really doing the phone tracing
thing that never works in the movies I
can trace a call in under 15 seconds
killer usually calls from somewhere
nearby and you think they're safe
because it's broad daylight in a public
place this is exactly how our Uncle
Randy died yes exactly yeah
Richie yep
why don't you just Trace Richie's fool
yeah I mean that'd be a solid lead it's
a clone of Richie's phone waiting for me
to call desperately hoping I'm nearby so
the police can grab me but I'm not
I'm a step ahead I got a VPN he's on the
upper west side on West 96th how did you
know that what Gail
no hello
handsome food it's for you
may ask who's calling please I was
wondering why there was never a black
ghost face he says it's the Killer
Jesus
it's her first phone call right she's
never been called hello Gail I don't
understand that you and I have never
spoken on the phone yeah confirmed don't
you know the Legacy characters are
disposable now nobody cares about oh
don't let them walk off
doing someone made a buck reporting your
death
it never works out for the [__] and
the mask
oh cool two killers I'm going three you
couldn't stop what happened to Dewey
just like you're not gonna be able to
stop this
get that one yeah you gotta have a gun
Gail yeah Sydney's got a gun
oh
yeah pan face
do not fall off the skyscraper please
get to the Panic Room
yeah shit's hard to work when you're
frightened yeah
how's that for nostalgia
best
they never have a bulletproof first on
yeah but this is new rules Andrew you
missed
sure I did
you win I'm in the elevator heading for
the ground floor
or maybe I'm wearing a bulletproof vest
good call can you hold please
huh
nice
uh you're running out of ammo or that
was smart but she must have shot the
wrong person like Scream 3 where she's
star 69s
[Music]
okay oh
gotten worse sometimes worse come on
oh this ghost face is so freaking
oh yeah
oh get up cute oh no come on girl
you got this don't go for the knife just
leave look at how beat up that thing is
too
mean ah [__]
[__] you
hey yes yes
damn fast terrible shots I mean you've
never gone to the range
there's still a chance too many times
she's been stabbed in her life
I'm just gonna take a little nap right
yeah please out of the way out of the
way come here okay there's there's a
chance there's a chance she's doing a
great job too Sam oh yeah they're both
great
I got you as fast as I could
and where were you I don't think it's
him they're not doing love interest two
movies in a row that's what they want
you to think she wants to punish me
so maybe I let him
I'll just give myself up if this is what
I have to do yes you have to let us
protect you this time
we're a team remember core four isn't
there somewhere like safe we could just
hole up in he's just gonna keep finding
us
great
you said though
hate him did anyone see Home Alone now
you want me to do what we want to lure
him to secure location and travel
cool you should assume there's two
killers guys
to the theater more people around you
voice doesn't sound too far from Ghost
yeah really I was just thinking that
Michael Myers that's crazy how they have
some Morrow Ravens character there from
Reddit or not I could see Kirby still
helping though yeah I just gotta throw
them all out there any possible scenario
so I could say I was right yeah bet on
all the horses to win one of them will
pay
no damn did you see the movie Speed get
on that thing
evil dies tonight
[Laughter]
they did the lament configuration
Freddy Krueger how many stops do we have
all of them
that's how many movies there will be
this was like the worst night to go
traveling
yeah
guys
we all float down here
that was really good
I believed it for a second
oh he's coming
this is really inventive
no
he's on the floor
damn it
no not Mindy
oh [__]
no ah [__] where's homeboy
somebody helps we gotta get your honey
okay
he let her live you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be okay
not you what don't trust anyone remember
we don't know you just like Jerry
O'Connell and scream 2. I cleared the
whole place before you got here
it's Kirby weapons one gun and I hold on
to it
I am the only one with a badge here and
that's the way it's gonna be um are
there any other entrances or exits you
know you're not safe here whenever
someone says we're safe here it means
you're not grab a weapon and clear this
place yourself kill your friends Kirby
yeah like how they have Stu mocker's
jacket right there a robe oh yeah they
got Tatum's outfit they got all sorts of
stuff in here
bro oh no they fired Jeremy two months
ago damn it unstable
she's no longer with the FBI yeah no
yeah damn you Kirby I was right
so Kirby and Ethan right no not Ethan
I'm trying to be halfway right here
maybe it's Kirby and the icky guy from
the party
just no I mean listen if you want them
you have them you think I want these
yeah kind of they're like 100 years old
maybe that's your thing I do like 100
year olds I actually well it's about
time and maybe we're seeing how long I
wanted to do that
yeah you should have done that a lot
sooner I know
we're supposed to do it like a lot more
times
we don't die
no no no no no no no
oh nice
let's go Chad let's go let's go come on
come on you could have stomped his head
hey what about that there's an exit door
let's go let's go Bailey's on the way
but
oh
God damn
it
yes
or at least in unmasking geez
amateurs
[Music]
no oh Chad the best chat that ever
chatted
[Applause]
I need you to be ready you ready
come on mother
it's okay
holy [__] right in you did you kill
Cohen did you kill my daughter Jesus
Christ whatever
this is good
[Laughter]
no yes
I knew it I called it at one point I
knew in my head I was thinking oh three
ah I did call that
what mixes
I got one right all right sure
and his daughter speaking of family wait
for it my name's not Ethan Landry
is it Dad yeah and that's the that's the
daughter the roommate this one
I had a feeling
how'd they fake a whole death yeah it
was a good way to get off the suspect
list a little fake blood a prosthetic
you'd be amazed at what a grieving
father can get away with jeez oh
interesting that's two
the sleeves
your fathers ah oh boy I'm gonna need
you to put it on join us
I didn't commit those murders in
Woodsboro it wasn't me well we know that
of course you didn't what do you think
this is based on some [__]
conspiracy theory who do you think
started the rumors about in the first
place
dang it's not enough to just kill
someone these days
you have to assassinate their character
first true when Dad here discovers your
horribly mutilated body he'll say some
poor dumb bastard right on the internet
that you're the real ghost face it's the
perfect alibi
you're a killer just like your father no
I'm not yes you are you mother
mother or you killed our brother
Ah that's what I got his phone Richie so
the whole family is really unstable yeah
runs in the franchise family Richie
I had a feeling it wasn't until I saw
that photograph of what you'd actually
done to him that I knew
then I knew you had to die you had to be
punished along with anyone else who
stands in our way he's uh like Nancy
Loomis the Dead real great parenting job
by the way
oh
what are the stab killers in the back
they're the same all the time yeah we're
all crazy
Kirby's gonna save them
that's why I helped him build this
collection
I built a tribute to my son which is why
this is where you have to die Sam
Now put on the mask
he was
that an insult it's like Sydney
insulting Billy he was a strong funeral
young man he was a lymph a little [__]
who cried before I slit his throat
oh yeah
ow
recognize this
[Music]
oh sorry oh my God I need this
that's insensitive what are you gonna do
about it [__] oh yep yep yep yeah
become your father enjoy it
accept your destiny yes this is holster
up yo this chick got so hot in this
movie
whatever your mom already
so funny he's just having a good time
now not scary but so far it's your last
scene go nuts do what you want
where's her boyfriend
oh let me go no
now let it go Sam no don't kill her off
no not her so just break another ankle
oh give her the knife
land on his face yes
oh she's enjoying it she's enjoyed it
she's enjoyed it oh wow
ouch
fine old girl oh she's enjoying it looks
like you're down another
oh
boy
looks like you're down to another child
[Laughter]
oh
oh Gail where are you
[Applause]
why did he charge him
no sense
[Laughter]
he was in the moment of Revenge he
wasn't thinking logically
[Music]
Scream one yes good reference I
understood that one hello Detective
um
Black Swan
laughs
all right I'm a police officer how do
you think this is gonna go Sam who do
you think they're gonna believe huh what
do you want for me
probably the one who's still alive
no no yes
oh
yeah look at her go wow everywhere
what the [__] are you doing you're not a
Loomis this is a really bad look for the
both of us
was a murderer you mean you're not gonna
kill this one
oh
no no do something that warrants it I
learned all you do it all the places to
stab without killing I love that look do
it come on oh you did with our family so
word good
nice meta to the end
if they wanted to go super meta they
should have had Dennis Quaid play
Richie's dead two two meta and then
we're gonna check on Kirby yeah she's
fine she said a bunch of stabs she's
been there before done that thank you
for letting me go I know you could take
care of yourself you too I don't trust
you with a drunk guy but two killers
you're good it's called a character Arc
oh final girls
[Applause]
oh yeah yeah Kirby she's the TV
[__] I saw that in a scary movie once
so did we
she's talking about Scream one nightmare
numbers three three right all the above
we're all part of the same
and Legacy doesn't always have to be a
bad thing the Disney sequels were okay
it's fine just to be average
Chad survived like do we
yeah
I'll take it he's like I'm the new Dewey
before
and then he died because he took off his
office
[Laughter]
[Music]
yep
yep it's okay there will be a scream
seven
yeah but she's really enjoying killing
she had a lot to the mask she held onto
the mess didn't she oh no
no no no no no no no oh she took it as a
souvenir no no
Sam
Embrace who you are Sam
yeah [__] that's evidence
dies tonight
ah the Big Apple
cool
I hear there's a post credit scene yes
oh
wow oh they didn't write it I thought
they wrote it
so it's the same directors as the last
one nice
my basic summary
of you I hated it we know we know
no that's not what I was going to say
were you here this whole time Andrew no
she produced it no wonder she lives okay
she couldn't throw a brighter painting
to death Campbell my basic summary is I
actually like this way more than the
last one agreed however I like the
motive
and the reveal of The Killers more in
the last one but other than that
I thought this was a much better film
overall yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I I the
only thing I heard about this was that
there was a big divide with the with the
reveal of who the Killer is and like
annoyed people that was the only thing I
heard I heard from like a lot of uh
you go on Twitter and be like that's why
I said like mute like a mother because I
was like just remove everything and then
uh that's all I heard that I did not
obviously know who it was but uh Roger
Jackson yeah I don't think it's that
upsetting is it no I I mean like the
actual circumstance that they should be
related to Richie like that I don't know
I have no idea why people were upset
like I don't mind it there has to be
some kind of connective tissue and that
makes sense especially going with you
know really riding on the new characters
and all that stuff you know committing
to the new characters but I like the
idea a lot
if they are doing like a secret origin
of the next Mexico phase yeah this whole
time that's what they've been doing
Corey Cunningham
do it if like Sam is really gonna be the
one I love that idea I understood that
reference by the way do you know I isn't
uh the guy who played uh uh you know
virgin guy isn't he freaking fighter and
Avatar
I mean maybe you're right you're usually
right about those things why that didn't
look like him
boy howdy Courtney Cox can stop billing
she's the EP okay she gets that role
yeah but I feel like I don't know
Melissa Barrera earned that no Sam I
really I really felt like this one did
become its own movie they did their own
thing they did weren't like I understand
the last one was so much about the
commentary on being a recall and all
that yeah but at the same time I felt
that commentary kind of hindered some of
the effect whereas this they really I
really cared about all the characters I
didn't want any of them to die yeah
except for like the random people I
didn't really give a [__] like that the
core four they want the core four to die
there's a lot of great twists and turns
throughout and there's a lot of style I
like that a lot I think you pointed out
too many times like this is one of the
scariest if not these scary well I guess
three ghost faces but I mean when we
were watching Ghostface like operate
throughout the film like and you really
felt the tension in each scene not that
you didn't in the other films but like
this ghost face was absolutely
Relentless and you could feel the anger
seeping through so when that actual
reveal does happen you know all I it is
very similar to Scream 2 with Nancy
Loomis getting revenge on her on her son
with Billy and all that but again you
just feel the intensity of this ghost
face so much more I feel like in this
film but I think the thing I love the
most in this yes the core four but the
relationship between Sam and Tara it was
so much more fleshed out in this film
and they just did such a great job with
those two characters I've loved every
scene that they were that they
interacted in and I remembered maybe you
felt the same way about me we weren't
huge fans like I would love Tara on the
last one but we weren't huge fans of Sam
in the last one yeah I thought she was
excellent here like yeah beginning to
end I thought she was excellent your
your best line was she's really hot in
this movie
well I mean the whole thing comes
together because yeah just the last
movie didn't feel like there was
something about it that didn't feel like
it flattered her performance very well
whereas here I feel like they really
made sure to like let her to shoot her
better and also just let her command the
screen like I thought the in between
scenes where you are just doing
character stuff were better handled in
this movie by far than the previous one
yeah because the previous one I felt
like was held back by a bit of a bit too
much reverence and and this one it was
at a weird Crossroads yeah because
because you know you have to please the
purists whereas this is less you know
it's less necessary for this to do that
but yeah I thought just the
believability of her expression her
relationship with Tara like yeah and
their relationship is the core for like
even the stuff with her being
overprotective could have been cliche
and annoying but I thought they handled
that in a very nuanced way and and yeah
she like whereas in the previous movie I
felt bad being like man you know there's
something about her that isn't working
like this one she yeah was like the
center figure I liked the most yeah yeah
I thought she was I think she might have
been my favorite character in her too
yeah totally and like even if she does
ascend to being the new ghost face as as
odd as that might be I love that choice
though like I won't be here to watch it
yeah I think that would be so cool my
favorite character was Courtney Cox's
boyfriend yeah he was great he yeah he
was he was he was the Crux of this film
he showed up man if he hadn't been there
she might have died true well I at these
directors whose names I constantly
forget but John will know radio silence
that's not their names it's their group
name
shut up shut up not every movie needs a
post-credit scene
yes it does who does the brand you have
to keep the bread that reminded me a
little of Spider-Man homecoming with
Captain America saying you waited this
long for something of disappoint
whatever it was I think it's it it's
like Tyler Gilpin and Matt bettinelli
open or something like that yeah
radio silence is what they go by that
sounds correct I would like to re-watch
it to see some stuff that I wonder if
lines up like there's three killers and
none of them look that tall but they all
except for dermit Maroney yeah but every
time his face never looks short every
time they were killing they were super
tall you know you all have platform
boots yeah I wasn't sure how this film
was going to play out in terms of this
is obviously our first film without Nev
Campbell Sydney of course and I didn't
think this film was hindered in any way
without her obviously of course it's you
do most just seeing the character of
Sydney of course she's just she's a
Legacy character she is the star of the
other films although you can make an
argumentary wasn't the star of the last
film because she was barely in it but
I this is one of my favorite scream
films so I was pleasantly surprised that
even with the absence of Nev Campbell of
course I would have loved to have seen
her in this even if it was a cameo role
I was pleasantly surprised that even
without her because I was a very big
concern coming into this film but I
didn't think the the storyline suffered
in any way it was nice to obviously get
a little shout out uh from her with Gail
of course but I thought the the
storyline was again the Crux of the
storyline for me that got me emotionally
invested was Tara and uh Sam I just I
really like the way they fleshed out
those characters and all their
interactions and like you said you just
really gave a [__] about all these
characters to the point you didn't want
anything to happen that's those are good
horror films to me when you can make
sure obviously we want the jump scares
we want the the graphic violence of
course but when you can't give a [__]
about the characters and you don't want
anything to happen that's those are the
best kind of horror films for me yeah
there's a solid installment great use of
Music throughout and I think these
directors who've worked I loved and
ready or not this felt like oh yeah they
made this movie yeah I understand it's
got all that punch in wit it's way more
gory than the other ones there's like
poppy gory people said it was like more
violent and yeah no it definitely is way
more violent yeah I like disturbingly
violent at times but it was always fun
to me I thought I thought it was a lot
of fun and and I was relieved to be like
yeah this ghost face is like the
Terminator you know he is non-stop
brutal and it has his eyes on a Target
and there wasn't just a bunch of like
jokey prat fall stuff it doesn't feel
like they have the meta angle here as
you would want from a Scream movie but
the meta quality isn't as front and
center as prior installments yes yes it
was more of like a like if there was
something that felt like personally
brutal about it you know like they had
the thing that would help
have a construct around your film
but it wasn't about the meta thing they
were clever to make the meta thing like
a really vital aspect of just how do we
figure our way out what can we use about
these movies and not rely on it for much
of any humor because I feel like in the
past we might have done a lot of both
yeah whereas this is pretty much them
kind of we we know that beat and I
thought they they yeah made it sort of
an intense sort of thing each time when
they did touch on the tropes of the
movies
um I'm not I really wish they handled
though
I think there's something about the way
they did the reveal reveal and this was
now like there is some there is
something about it that I don't I don't
mind the decision I really don't mind
that this it's a little far-fetched like
I think that the strip with Quinn very
far-fetched the fact like how faking the
daughters like that one
very far you've got a witness across the
window there like yeah that isn't
that's a little that part is a little
much two-thirds of that I'm totally okay
with sure but Quinn being alive was like
uh
I don't know man that's a lot for me to
wrap my head and the moment I wasn't
really thinking about it because I was
so was caught up in like what the
reveals are well they they show you a
lot whereas I feel like I may be putting
it too off screen would clue Us in but I
feel like if they maybe didn't give you
so much to go off in that and more
played it from the outside room
perspective we gotta have like a corner
you gotta have an autopsy
he said he switched the bodies that
right is that what he said or something
like that and he passed it off it's like
there's a lot you could do as a cop but
I'm like yeah that's a pretty that's a
tall order there's a lot of people now
you're in like some weird Saw movie
territory at that point I mean there
were there were shades of Saw throughout
this and I think smartly to bring in a
more direct like police angle I was like
okay seven and other other police throw
does that make sense but at the end it
did remind me of a Saw movies twist
ending well I know the cliche with I
felt like this movie was really doing
its own thing until they got to the
reveal of the killers and then they all
started behaving leaving like there's
something about I don't know why they
they always everyone becomes stew Billy
and Stu were the perfect ones the
perfect reveal and the right level and
then they they kind of made a decision
like every movie following this they all
have to be and I thought I thought Jack
Quaid actually hit a really good level
and experience when it came to the
reveal I thought he hit a perfect level
and then Derma Mulroney was like what
the hell just happened with terminal
take it away
[Music]
he's so comical so cartoony yeah I like
to watch him have fun but it does
transcend into a much wackier movie it
was very it went too wacky it didn't hit
the tone of the rest of the film where
yeah you got to strike that it's not
easy but you do got to strike that
balance whereas as you just mentioned
Billy and Stu like it fit perfectly with
that film and then in other films
they've just taken it a step too far
yeah I did like the motif with
um and and the commentary on the here
and now about how like it's very easy to
go online in places like that and just
into the public conversation and twist
and warp people's lives and cast images
that people run away with like yeah it's
like so much of the context for them was
great but it it it it just felt like
yeah so many so many like wacky
hillbilly movies by the end I don't I
don't hate it so I I might have I might
I might not like it more
if I didn't hear that there were some
people who really hated it you know and
so that prepared me for I might hate
what comes up but I don't hate it and I
think what they did with Kirby was smart
that was because they did restrain her
for compare and they and they Justified
it within the character of why she would
be more restrained and not you know like
the uh Plucky teenager who says yeah
and I think the the performance was so
intentional so that way you could
suspect her because I was told that it
was her like I I did get sold on it and
then I saw the run time and I was like
maybe it's on her yeah wow and I don't
know I mean the second they gave her
that like suspicious walk-off in the
second yeah it's like oh no her trap I'm
like it can't be you just can't and uh
yeah like I I wish almost that there had
been a little bit more for her to do
that's because there were times where I
was like the Kirby's not as involved in
this like she seemed like she was here
kind of to be a red herring in a way as
instead of being like a fully ingrained
member see I don't feel like I feel like
they know how to use Gale and they knew
how to use Dewey but I didn't I feel
like they really didn't know what to do
with Sydney in the last one as much as I
love seeing Nev Campbell yeah
um I felt like they didn't really know I
felt like she was kind of forced in the
movie she went for a run in the movie
well it makes sense because yeah she's
gonna be like so used to this that she's
not even gonna be involved in the plot
probably and I think they made that
choice for Kirby specifically because
like I think that's where they come at a
Crossroads again is uh you know you you
see Kirby's back and you kind of want a
little bit of the flare of what you
remember about Kirby and you kind of get
none of that about her other than the
fact that it's Hayden Panettiere again
and and you also get an interesting
kernel in that they use that like oh her
life's really spiraled off the tracks
and she's not even been on the force for
a couple months and I was like I don't
know like at least in the resolve maybe
we could have had some emotional payoff
because this is a character people are
excited to see a return a fan favorite
from scream for I agree they did
restrain her but we did get that one
scene with her and Mindy where they were
having their little yeah I was like
that's the Kirby we know but I mean
understand I did like though how they uh
what they did with Sam and Tara in
regards to you know from Sydney's
perspective in terms of Scream 2 after
this ordeal that she had just gone
through in terms of the trust issues and
in terms of the trauma that she uh has
to deal with you have Tara with I just
want to move on with my life and then
you have Sam this celebrity that
everyone you know ostrates whenever they
see her in public so I thought that was
really interesting choice of making
giving both of those characters traits
of Sydney from Scream 2 so I thought
that was a really wise decision for both
their characters yeah and I think these
last couple movies especially with I
mean Sydney so much about her character
too was someone who was ostracized by
society as well as during certain
moments of her life and then sort of
watching the way Sam is being has been
ostracized as well and watching her
morph
has been fun and that's why I'm I'd
actually be kind of on board for her
being like a killer the next one you
were thinking because they they did
continue off of the heels of the last
one where she did enjoy killing the I
don't know I don't want to see a third
Arc of her being like I'm not gonna be
much you know like I can't watch that
three times it would be different if
they did that because we've never seen
the heroes become that I think that
would be so cool that would be different
well and there was something they did in
the prologue that made me think of that
because as much as like it might be a
meme for this movie to have turned into
like oh there's a bunch of them there's
a cult like having the two copycats at
the beginning who are your kind of stock
screen characters but who are now taking
this game out of the personal and into a
more broad-scoping thing I was like is
this going to be a ghost face killing
people who weren't involved with the
ghost face Legacy who are like
disrespecting it somehow so like I feel
like you could almost
warp it in on itself that way with her
where she has some kind of motive that
isn't just pure evil I got another
question about that sure yeah sure yeah
yeah
some stuff is really starting to [__] me
a little bit nitpicks in order I don't
know if it's an epic man
I'm just I'm anticipating comments in
order for this
in order for this plant to have hatched
and worked
he they would have needed to move to
specifically New York City
where he is the cop yes the head of like
the police department it's not hard to
get a transfer to a specific police
station did he say he transferred I
don't know maybe not that I recall we're
looking too deep into this I agree with
you no no I agree with you I agree with
you yeah I mean like I could buy them
being obsessed in enough to have found
their way there but to to set up a
career as a cop in the amount of time
that would take or to translate it seems
like it would be a lot you bought this
whole place under the name of the rich
people and built this whole Shrine and
the I'm like it seems like they've been
established like they grew up here
they're established where is she from
Modesto they say that he is from Modesto
in uh no he is not from Modesto he like
him and Amber hatched that plan he is
not from Modesto no way so they really
planted the seeds there from like but
this guy had to be a in law enforcement
and he also got the Kate oh I mean
I don't know I just assume he could bug
or track her phone or whatever but but
but yes having it be so clean that he is
a New York cop in the last what six
months that they've lived here if they
didn't already live here either begs a
huge coincidence or just some kind of
weird explanation that we didn't get I
mean yeah I mean like the two the
children make sense that you could just
transfer them in yeah like okay I I
understand that
yeah that's a psychotic family right
never underestimate Revenge
um yeah man yeah that was that that was
fun but overall it was a very fun movie
with some Great Kills and I think uh I
love the sound design on this movie with
headphones was very rewarding shotguns
and knife skills yeah they have some
great sound design here and some
fantastic editing as well and I thought
they embraced like their cinematography
their style like the the sleekness yet
the ickiness of it I thought was perfect
you know I I thought they might do a
little bit more like New York [__] oh
yeah but they did enough for me that
wasn't like about like watch New York
settings you know but like the
convenience store uh the subway station
uh the the subway train I thought had a
lot of great tension to it yeah because
you're going between high buildings and
things yeah there I thought they did
enough uh we don't need a Times Square
and So Meta to show Jason Takes
Manhattan of course yeah and they're in
New York and we were literally just
talking about that before we started
filming I mean that is that is a
requirement that they include like if
they didn't include a very obvious
Easter egg I feel like people would have
right I knew this is Super Fresh because
we just watched this but any idea where
you would rank this in your scream
rankings are too too early too yeah
above three
are you sure is that like not ranking
above Mission Impossible too sure uh I
mean it's definitely above three and
five
I would agree with that I don't know if
I would need to watch it it's got a
fight with four yeah in the middle yeah
one and two still Reigns Superior I
might like four more than two now
I use them fighting words I used to it
used to be an easy like one two four for
me but then when I re-watched four is
good when I rewatch The Scream movies
last year
um I was like oh [__] you know I might
prefer four yeah four was underrated it
was a little ahead of its time yeah I
agree um yeah I like I like four a lot
uh so I was especially excited to see
like yeah I think there's some fantastic
sequences before but man that caught
this the scene in the and uh when they
have to escape over when they're in the
police car and they have to climb over
him in part two oh that's one of the
greatest tension moments
like it's not so scary when you re-watch
it because you know it's completely yeah
first time you watched it that was a
scary [__] I've ever seen yeah
I did also like that sequence where
they're on the subway and the the lights
are just going in and out in the strobe
light I thought that was a really cool
sequence as well yeah like this really I
thought there was more even though like
they take the city to bigger and while
you have some some new characters like
they they have the joke about the core
four but I really felt like this movie
really focused I thought they really
focus in hard on their character then
really knew how to do it was in the last
movie ever kind of sometimes forget
about them
um well and you have to keep track of
who all them are yeah like this was like
Tara insane this was Sam's this is a
salmon terror story they're the heart of
it and them having to
you know grow together and I I what I
liked too was that they they paid
attention to the fact that they are all
of them are trauma survivors of the
situation and I thought it was really
smart of them from a character
standpoint to be like look we all
survived together but yeah none of us
can understand what you're like when
Tara is talking with her like none of us
can actually understand what you're
going through because this is you're
getting this on a whole other level than
yeah than us you know and that must be
so not only that but it's I felt like I
agree with everything you just said but
I also feel like it's not only that that
you're getting on a different level but
you're also the daughter of Pilkey
Loomis so that's something also that
none of us can relate to as well exactly
so you're factoring all that and where
she has her own identity struggle
because
um you know it's like you have there's
like several forms of PTSD and you know
like like one form of what is the uh I
forget the actual terminology but
there's like a PTSD version where it's
like yeah you experience it like the way
Tara laid it out I thought was
interesting to hear I'm not gonna let
these three days to find my life like oh
[__] that was just three days huh but
but that's like okay a PTSD situation
that you definitely got to work on but
then you have like levels of like
complex PTSD where [__] you you've like
grew up with it and you've had to endure
it and she it's like lifestyle things
and that's more of what Sam has had to
deal with on top of the actual you know
killings and [__] as well being
inflicted her way uh so she has a whole
new kind of psychological Journey she
has to go through because I've not I've
never been a big fan of this whole like
skeet old Rich showing up [__] because
it just messes with my logic of how does
she know like how he would talk and
sound like and whatever and and it I I
have a hard time buying into it because
it's like he behaved so much like he did
she watches she watched Scream one okay
too much stab one yeah just replace that
actor's face let's get over it yeah
like videos about how he behaved as a
killer she watched some Roman's videos
but I'm not saying that anything's gonna
come about it but I thought it was an
interesting reference to mention uh
stu-macher because again originally he
was supposed to be in Scream 3 and then
I I could be wrong let me know in the
comment section I believe because of the
Columbine shooting that happened around
that same time they kind of asked the
idea of having him so you're right I'm
curious if that anything comes about
that because they were asking in the
film if I remember correctly like where
is he what's going on so he lives who
lives one and all these character things
just real quick like as much as it seems
like blasphemy not to have nav Campbell
I thought that it actually kind of
served the movie not to have to to find
something for Sydney Prescott to do
don't force her in here yeah and I
thought that let everybody shine and
then Gail is just the right amount of
here and as your main Legacy character
and then did you know the scream tropes
enough though when you're like oh okay
okay
the second the EMT
I actually did think before the film
started I was anticipating like that was
the Legacy character well she was the
only real Legacy character oh besides uh
Kirby but I thought she was gonna not on
the heels running out of [__] for Gail
to do it is the same [__] every time you
got a boyfriend she got a boyfriend in
this one she's just like oh Gail you
disappoint me by going back to being a a
freaking snake journalist and and oh
she's gonna go off the Record now and
start helping out yeah
every time with her yes
it can you know she should be the wipe
away character it is the same thing like
every single movie second movie it's
been the same thing no I mean no no no
no no no no it's the character yeah as
someone who like loves friends like
friends with my all-time probably my
favorite it's my favorite comedy show of
all time
um who loves friends and knows like
Monica Geller so well it's it is crazy
to me to be like I only see Gail
weathers when I watch this franchise
like I'm not like I could see like
Matthew Perry or something with the
group Chandler I could think yeah but
then when it comes to her here I'm like
oh yeah I just see Gail weathers and I
think she embodies this character and I
love the presence of her and I was I
would be I was gonna be like heartbroken
to see her ago at the same time I'm like
you got to come up with a different way
to introduce her yeah
I I agree with you I mean they could
have played off too even though they
they did go into it a little bit just
how she's dealing with you know the
death of doing again they did go into it
I'm not saying they didn't but just play
a little bit even more into that I I do
I gotta interrupt I love the way that
phone call with her was handled because
when when Dewey like you were saying was
brought up you know and you see her
getting emotionally triggered by that
and coming to tears on it but then she
has to find that resilience again to
like power through the situation I'm
like oh that actually feel like that was
one of my favorite as much as I'm making
fun of like they just keep introducing
her the same way in all these movies
that was one of my all-time favorite
Gale scenes sure I think the point I was
I agree with you but I think the point I
was trying to make is instead of just
doing the same thing over the could have
played even more into that because I did
love that moment as well just a little
more is all I'm saying as opposed to
just doing the same thing like I'm gonna
write a book again and that's all I'm
saying but uh I think my biggest issue
with this movie is they didn't do Dennis
Quaid uh as Richie's father I think that
would have been the ultra medicine
see really really he's a hardcore
Republican oh damn it so Oh I thought it
was rain I thought it was Randy no
I'm pretty sure the Quaid family or the
jack is all right
it's a different movie at the end and
it's not like a mind-blowing motive but
he's still fun to watch it he is he is I
was gonna say I think Jack Quaid's gonna
change his last name to Ryan for obvious
reasons but yeah yeah I thought the I
mean the kills the kills being more
brutal reflected the motive of it being
more personal so I think that that in
itself works I thought the I just I just
thought it was kind of I thought it was
pretty inventive what they as much as I
I wasn't as in love with Scream five as
a lot of other people were I thought the
motive was like oh that's pretty smart
how they lay that out yeah and I didn't
feel like any of this was like oh that's
close
okay
we've got a lot of shades of screen too
in this from Nancy loomis's revenge for
Billy so for sure that Personal Touch of
Revenge absolutely I think I would come
around to that thing you said earlier
though for me is like yeah I prefer most
of this but I do think the original
movie has a clever more clever like
chassis underneath the car yeah you know
but uh yeah but if this movie at the
same time doesn't feel like it's a ever
a Crossroads with itself at a really
allowed them to just get to know the
characters they invented for this
franchise and and let them become their
own and like I loved I I love I thought
they were all great I thought I thought
all of them were great yeah I would be
happy to see all of them return I would
look forward to these new characters
scream seven torch past scream seven the
core four
yeah yeah how are they gonna warp the
title next time
um
yeah all right guys well uh for me I
guess I would give this like uh I give
this like a solid six steps
yeah those kids those stabs were brutal
yeah
are you sure this movie's already yeah
director commentaries it's the first
thing to come out is this stab scene was
40 and we whacked it down to three it's
still so pulpy though sure it's still so
I I was under the impression the way
people talked about the violence that it
would be just like Rob Zombie a little
silence or just like I don't enjoy this
this isn't Fun violence like to me they
still to me the violence was still fun I
still I still thought the violence was
like still heightened and pulpy enough
and just like just ah this is fun yeah
just the right amount of fun and then
that New York City just like they hit
the ground running and it's nasty but it
never loses that you know pulp I think
that is the thing about New York City
that does resonate over here is the
aggression of New York City so like the
vibe yeah that that registers over here
more than like going to like they were
fighting Statue of Liberty
Liberty we're a Times Square rooting
we're getting a hot dog they either
should have done that or had Ghostface
punch someone's head off just clean off
with his fist yes oh that would have
been awesome yeah all right guys well
this was a a really fun movie I would
probably give it like uh like my first
viewing I'm like a
89 oh that's good what is it that is
damn that is that's a great score I
would give it like nah I bump it to 90.
I'll give it like a nine right I really
enjoy I really enjoyed this would you
give what would you give Scream one just
curious oh scream one's like a hundred
percent excuse me like a 65 I don't I
don't think there's I was just curious
what the bro I don't think I have a
single flaw first for screen one ice
cream one is my favorite horror movie of
all time I I I I love that movie and
every time I decide to re-watch it it's
great it just gets better and it becomes
like my favorite one film class study of
why this movie works so much and that
and enough none none of the movies in
this franchise have taught the the last
hour of the first one sure the last half
hour the first one all let's do Stu's
party night is so it's so perfectly
constructive yes yeah and iconic yeah
like that whole thing
it's a lot of people forget like that
that's like a whole like 30 to 40
minutes sequence that's all just taking
place at on Stu's party at night you
know and it just builds it oh it's
perfect and that movie too was like such
a Splash In terms I remember people at
the time when I was too young to see it
being like this actually really
Disturbed this feels like real crime
yeah for the time very grounded not
Supernatural yep oh yeah yeah that was
the real mentals I mean yeah the the
commentary here is like the meta
commentary here is not is nowhere near
as clever as I mean I I appreciated the
meta commentary and I thought what they
wanted to do with the granite commentary
and the fifth one was really was good at
least the the intention a lot and there
were some there's a lot of cleverness in
The Meta commentary here was really just
about them explaining why they can do
different things yeah
really riffing on like you know like I
thought they were gonna Riff on you know
like now they were doing this you know
reboot we got it they're gonna be more
yeah yeah we're gonna ignore details
from the past
it's only a sequel just two yeah yeah
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below Andrew thanks for being here
you're welcome thanks for having me
thanks for not stabbing me Nancy Loomis
and uh Scream 2 and uh John thanks for
being me sure and uh John uh say hi to
Greg hi Greg and uh hey thanks for uh
checking us out Flex
oh
foreign
[Music]